Mother's Day is just around the corner
and we have teamed up with pure leaf to
celebrate and joining me is New York
Times best-selling author award-winning
journalist and mom to a baby boy please
welcome back to the show my friend
Elaine Walter rod
okay
I'm so excited because the last time I
saw you on the show you were pregnant
yes and since then you have had a
beautiful baby boy I can't I can't even
take it oh my God I'm gonna try not to
cry on this show but yes everything with
my kids makes me so emotional that's why
they're always like Mom don't cry
because everything brings me to tears
I'm like the mushiest mom I I ca I can't
even like the way that this little tiny
actually huge juicy human with the
thickest thighs you guys get into the
juicy rolls but that little cinnamon
roll has just melted my heart in a way I
just didn't even anticipate
[Applause]
life like being a mom yes but the love
and the shifts is really vital well I
mean I don't know if anyone ever knows
but all I ever drink is iced tea and tea
I'm a tea fanatic you know how they say
we're 98 water I'm 98 teeth I know it I
love that well there's a great tea in
front of us and we thought it would be
fun if we spilled the tea on some mom
moments will you do that with Eileen I
love that
let's do it okay I'm gonna name a mom's
friend and if you're here for it you
take a sip and if not no Sip and you
explain why okay okay with the T right
all right first mom Trend okay packing
elaborate lunches for your child with
handwritten notes I want to be that Mom
I want to like write a little cute note
and all that stuff so yeah when I have
time when I make the time let's do it I
have to say I'm with you
next mom Trend dressing up for school
drop off I'm gonna give you guys a
little like a half sip on that because I
think 50 of the time I'm gonna turn up
in looks but then the other 50 of the
time it'll look like I just crawled out
of like under a bridge well as editor
you know in Chief of Teen Vogue when you
were there you are one of the most
stylish women I mean look at these shoes
they're wrapped around your
all right last Trend mom jeans of course
like what's wrong with mom jeans I think
mom jeans are totally bad what do you
guys think
mom jeans are hot yeah I'm into it all
right well tell me about your
partnership with pure leaf because being
98 tea I'm very curious it all started a
year ago when I started this maternity
series
um when I was pregnant and I felt so
lost and I felt like I didn't have
guidance or information about how to
navigate this crazy journey into
motherhood and I just remember thinking
like wouldn't it be so cool to partner
with an actual Tea Company to Spill the
tea about all the things no one tells
you to Expect When You're Expecting yes
and the pure leaf no grants campaign
really gives moms an extra Financial
resource to help them determine how to
free up their time in a way that just
makes sense for them the most powerful
thing you can say as a mom sometimes is
just no right like you have the pressure
and the weight of the world and your
family on your back and there is a lot
of pressure to do it all and do it
perfectly and so so the idea here is to
give moms actual tangible support and
resources that allow you to say no
sometimes it's not just about saying
that you stand with moms it's about
putting your money where your mouth is
and you decide how to free up your time
in a way that works for your
circumstances whether that's like going
to get a massage or paying for a
housekeeper or paying for some child
care for the week just so that you can
come back to yourself and really show up
for yourself so that you can show up for
your family I'm all about that
always been someone who supports people
and now that your son is turning one
this campaign makes perfect sense and
you know lockstep with who you've always
been so let's spill the tea for all the
money yes I love that I love you thank
you so much I am so thrilled thank you
Elaine and thank you purely
[Music]
foreign